So today we're going to talk about
Freud.
Freud is probably perhaps the most
controversial of the psychological
theory risers that we're,
that we've been discussing in the,
in the first part of this course.
Um,
I don't know what it is about Freud
exactly.
People really like to give him a rough
time,
even though it's quite clear that many
of the things we take for granted as
psychologist today,
we're first introduced into the public
realm of knowledge by Freud.
Now Freud would say that the reason that
people are so upset with his theorizing
is that they don't like the implications
of what he says and that he could have
predicted that as a consequence of his
theory because Freud talks about things
that people don't really like to talk
about.
And,
uh,
I think there's a lot of truth to that.
I also think that Ford was one of those
people who was
right at some levels of analysis and not
so right.
It others.
But,
but I would say that even where he
wasn't right,
he was helpful,
he wrong.
And a theory can be helpfully wrong if
it's better than the theory that it
replaced.
Just like a
hammer is a better tool for chopping
down a tree than a ranch.
It's not as good as an ax.
But,
but if you conceptualize conceptual
schemes as tools,
then you can also understand how a
better tool is an improvement even
though it's not necessarily right.
And a lot of the clinical theories are
quite tool like given that they're
applied to the problems of,
of poor mental health.
So,
and I don't really think of clinical
psychology precisely as a science
because it's an applied science and that
makes it more like a form of
engineering.
I mean it can be based on scientific
insight,
which,
and it appropriately is,
but it straddles,
as we've discussed,
the space between value in science.
And so the theories have to be
hybrid.
A strange hybrid.
I'm gonna play you a little recording
and this is the only recording that was
ever made of Freud.
Strangely enough.
I mean the recording technology was
there,
but it's only a minute and 23 seconds
long.
So I'll play that and then we'll do a
fairly comprehensive job of walking
through Freud's theory.
And then on Tuesday I'm going to show
you some movie clips because it like as
with young,
one of the best ways to understand Freud
is to actually see some examples of what
he was talking about.
Now those examples are hard to come by.
It has,
it turns out,
but I have a movie that there is a
movie.
I should rephrase that.
That does a great job of it.
Really a great job.
So,
okay,
so here's the recording.
Whew.
Whew,
whew,
whew.
Mine.
Why?
Okay.
So I'm going to give you some historical
background so that you can understand
the context within which Freud was
operating.
Now the reason I'm going to do this
because you might think,
well,
why is the history necessary?
And part of the reason it's necessary is
because
mental disorders such as they are,
have a sociological element.
And so you might,
you might think about it this way,
the human brain is obviously predisposed
to learn languages.
So there's a biological substrate for
language learning.
We don't really understand it.
You can think of it as a capacity,
although that doesn't help.
But when you launch a baby into the
world and the baby encounters a
linguistic community,
he or she learns to speak very,
very rapidly,
but the languages are different
depending on the culture and mental
illnesses are like that.
So you can think,
well
there can be biological disruption at
one level of analysis.
Sorry about that guys.
There can be biological disruption at
one level of analysis and maybe that
biological disruption in some sense is
somewhat constant across cultures,
but then the manner in which the
disturbance manifests itself,
the specific manner is going to be
shaped by the culture.
And then of course,
and this is a Friday and idea because
culture battles against the individual
to some degree and so that's sort of the
idea of the Super Ego against the ID.
Then the battle between the individual
and culture is going to take forms that
differ with the culture because
sometimes in some parks there's going to
be trouble in this society with regards
to incorporating one set of drives and
other times there's going to be trouble
incorporating another set of drives.
And so for Freud
in Freud's time,
sexuality was very heavily,
it was very problematic.
I don't think it's exactly appropriate
to say that it was repressed.
I would say that more,
more that it was extraordinarily
problematic.
And the reason for that is that sex is
extraordinarily problematic for all
sorts of reasons.
One of the main reasons is part from
pregnancy apart from unwanted pregnancy.
Um,
apart from the passions that sexual
attraction in flames,
it's also an incredibly effective vector
for the transmission of disease.
And so part of the reason that people
have mixed motives and with regards to
their sexual behavior is because
like eating sex is one of those
activities that can also potentially be
contaminating.
And one of the things that happened in
the Victorian era was that
when the,
when the Europeans came to North
America,
they carried a variety of different
illnesses,
measles,
mumps,
small smallpox.
Those were very,
very hard on the native American
population and wipe about 95% of it out
there is a theory that syphilis was the
reverse gift and then it was brought to
the old world by the new world.
It was the only illness as far as anyone
knows,
that had that particular characteristic.
Anyways,
it was a devastating illness.
Syphilis mean,
um,
it was certainly the syphilis problem in
Europe in the late 19 hundreds with
certainly as serious as they age crisis
in the 20th century,
which is still to some degree running
out,
especially in developing countries,
but is,
has been somewhat controlled.
And so
we're also very,
very rigid gender roles.
And that was pretty true,
I would say around the world until
the 20th century and probably really
until the 1950s or thereabouts when,
because it was at the end of the fifties
that the birth control pill was invented
and the birth control pill was what
propelled the political movements that
facilitated the movement of women into
the workplace and on mass by the 1970s.
I mean people like to attribute that to
political,
to political pressure,
but without the biological
transformation,
that political pressure would have been
pointless.
So,
so I think it's hard for modern people
to understand how problematic sex was
for the victorians.
Um,
there's a conflict between propagation
of the species and the happiness and
health of the,
of a particular individual.
And it's a difficult
problem to solve,
especially because children are
dependent for so long.
So
this is from on [inaudible] who wrote a
great book.
If you're really interested in
psychoanalytic thought,
this is the best book you can read as an
introduction.
That's called the discovery of the
unconscious.
Um,
and a lot of what I'm going to tell you
about Freud,
although I've read a fair bit of Freud,
I took from the discovery of the
unconscious because it's re it's
regarded as the best scholarly work that
was ever done on the history of the
psychoanalytic movement and also on
Freud and young and Adler.
And so Alan Jay,
who is an existential psychotherapist
who lived in Montreal at least when he
was older
at produced a very even handed
historical representation of the
precursors to the idea of the
unconscious and then a Freud's theories
and young's theories and Adler's
theories.
So,
so here's what the world was like.
It was a world shaped by man for man in
which women occupied the second place.
Political Rights for women did not
exist.
The separation and dissimilarity of the
sexist was sharper than today.
Women who wore slacks or wore their hair
shorter smoked were hardly to be found.
The university's admitted no female
students until the early 1890s man's
authority over his children and also
over his wife was unquestioned.
Education was authoritarian.
The despotic father was a common figure
and was particularly conspicuous only
when he became extremely cruel.
Laws were more repressive,
delinquent youth,
sternly punished and corporal punishment
was considered indispensable.
Sexual repression,
supposedly characteristic of the
Victorian psyche was often merely the
expression of two facts,
the lack of diffusion of contraceptives
in the fear of venereal disease.
Now there's another issue as well
because because employment
opportunities,
we are extraordinarily limited for women
for a variety of reasons.
It was also very,
very problematic if a woman became
pregnant outside of wedlock.
And the other thing really necessary to
understand is that people in the late 18
hundreds didn't have very much money.
You know,
even in the civilized world,
so to speak,
in the late 18 hundreds,
the average amount of money in today's
terms that people lived on was about a
dollar a day.
So it's almost impossible for us to
imagine how much wealthier we are now
than then.
People were only 120 years ago.
So,
so there were three factors that made
sexuality difficult to integrate.
One was the,
the sheer danger of pregnancy for women.
Um,
and then disease.
And then the fact,
well,
the fact associated with that,
that we're no contraceptives,
venereal disease was all the more
dangerous because of the great spread of
prostitution and because prostitutes
were almost invariably contaminated and
therefore potential sources of
infection.
We can hardly imagine today how
monstrous syphilis appeared to people of
that time made worse by the fact that it
was likely to be transmitted to the next
generation in the form of hereditary
syphilis,
which in turn had become a nightmarish
myth.
And to which many physicians attributed
all diseases of unknown origin while in
syphilis was was andy is a particularly
problematic pathogen because it produces
a massive range of symptoms.
And so there's no telling what form it
will necessarily take in one victim
compared to another.
So
the victorians had no shortage of
reasons to be in serious conflict about
sexuality.
Now,
Freud was also very much influenced by
niches.
Ellenberger g says that psychoanalysis
belongs to that unmasking trend.
The search for hidden unconscious
motivations characteristic of the 1880
[inaudible] 1890s in freud as a
Nietzsche words and deeds are viewed as
manifestations of unconscious
motivations,
mainly of instincts and conflicts have
instincts for both men.
The unconscious is the realm of the
wild,
brutish instincts that cannot find
permissible.
Outlets derive from earlier stages of
the individual and of mankind and find
expression in passion,
dreams,
and mental illness.
Now,
you know,
it seems to me,
and I,
I don't know if it's,
if it also seems to you that these are
sorts of things that we take for granted
now that people don't always say what
they mean,
that their speech and their actions are
unfleet influenced by factors,
that they're not necessarily conscious
of.
That some of the drives or the
motivational states that people that are
characteristic of people influenced the
manner in which they speak influenced
their dreams and influence their actions
in ways that are difficult to discover.
And that passions and dreams and mental
illnesses are manifestations of the
unconscious.
And so you see what happens to a thinker
whose ideas are rapidly integrated into
the culture.
And that was the case with Freud despite
the fact that he said there was great
resistance and there was,
but I mean the idea is that he put
forth,
we're integrated into into Western
culture during his lifetime,
which is a staggeringly fast from
historical perspective.
When you absorb a great thinkers,
ideas and those become axioms.
Now they're,
they're,
they're what people assume then all
that's really left of what their thing
they think is what's the error,
right?
Cause the errors of course don't become
incorporated and then the thinker just
gets blamed for his errors.
So and that's certainly something that
happened to Freud.
Even the term id which actually means it
originates from niches,
the dynamic concept of mind with the
notions of mental energy,
Quanta of latent or inhibited energy or
release of energy or transfer from one
drive to another is also to be founded
in each year before Freud nature
conceived the mind as a system of drives
that can collide or be fused into one
another.
Okay.
In contrast to Freud,
however neat,
did not give prevalence to the sexual
drive whose importance he duly
acknowledged,
but too aggressive and self destructive
drives need.
She also understood those processes that
the Freud Ian's called defense
mechanisms,
particularly sublimation to sublimate.
Something is to take a form of energy
like sexual energy,
let's say,
and,
and pour it into something else.
Now the sublimation ideas,
very interesting.
One because for Freud it was more of an
individual issue.
So if,
if,
uh,
one,
once he thought of Sexual Energy Libido
as,
as a kind of in some sense of free
energy was a source of energy that the
psyche could use.
And because it was in some sense of free
source of energy,
it could be channeled into other
activities.
And so,
you know,
one of the obvious examples of that
would be paintings of nudes for example,
um,
or into creativity in general.
And,
and Freud actually believed that the
reason that people became civilized was
because we learned how to sublimate our
instinctual energies into,
um,
forms of activity and thought that were,
that were acceptable in the social
community.
Now,
the funny thing about the idea of
sublimation is that I think it actually
works better as a phylogenetic,
um,
hypothesis then as an entouch genetic
hypothesis.
So,
and here,
here's why.
MMM.
It is certainly the case that one of the
reasons that people are creative,
especially one of the reasons that men
are creative is because if a man is
successfully creative and that makes him
successful,
the probability that he's going to have
a wider choice of mates,
or at least the possibility of what he
might consider a higher quality mate
goes up immensely.
And that's partly because women,
unlike their closest biological
relatives,
which are the chimpanzees are extremely
selective maters and women tend to mate
across and up dominance hierarchies.
And,
and this looks like a biological
propensity.
It's the case for women all around the
world.
It's also as far as we can tell,
the source of the rapid expansion of
human creative ability and intelligence.
It's,
it's true just as much in egalitarian
societies as it is in societies that are
extremely unequal.
Um,
and it's also one of the major causes
now of income inequality.
Because one of the things that's
happened is that as women have become
educated,
like educated men will marry on educated
women,
but educated women will not marry on
educated man.
And so one of the,
one of the,
one of what's what's happened as we've
transformed our society increasingly
into an intellectual meritocracy that
also allows the contribution of
conscientiousness,
is that we've getting assorted of mating
between smart and conscientious people
at the upper strata of the socioeconomic
distribution.
And the estimates now are that about 25%
of its income inequality in North
America as a consequence of,
of,
of the fact that women will only meet
across or up dominance hierarchies.
So they won't,
they're looking for someone who is at
least as competent as they are or more
competent.
So depending of course on what you mean
by competent,
whereas men are not the correlation
between women socioeconomic status and
their mating opportunity.
Is it slightly negative?
The correlation between men
socioeconomic status and their mating,
uh,
potential so to speak is about 0.5 0.6
like that's a massive difference.
It's an unbelievably massive difference
and has very powerful sociological
consequences.
Nature well understood.
Those processes that have been called
defense mechanisms by Freud,
particularly sublimation repression and
the turning of instincts towards oneself
both give a new expression to did arose
old assumption that modern man is
afflicted with a peculiar in illness
bound up with civilization because of
civilization demands of man,
that he renounced the gratification of
his instincts.
Now.
So for Freud and and for neat shed,
they,
they both,
they both adopted a perspective that was
different from that of piaget.
And I think piaget was actually correct
for Freud,
the individuals striving upwards to
manifest their true nature,
which is in some ways can be quite
brutish.
And what the Superego is doing,
what society is doing is actually
inhibiting.
It's stopping it from happening.
So it's basically,
it's,
it's as if society puts each individual
into a jail cell of sorts and only
allows them to do certain things within
that cell.
Now you can certainly understand that.
And I,
I think that is true.
The more tyrannical as society becomes.
And as Ellen Borchez pointed out,
Victorian society was quite
authoritarian.
And the more authoritarian a society,
the more there is a struggle between the
individual attempting to be an
individual and the culture attempting to
turn into an absolutely predictable cog
in a machine.
But you know,
pier,
so Freud of course viewed the primary
conflicts and mental life as the ego
tortured by the end in some sense,
right?
Being driven by underlying biological
forces but also severely inhibited and
repressed by the Super Ego.
Um,
you know,
it's a,
it's,
if it's a perfectly persuasive model and
there are situations under which it's
more applicable,
but piaget's idea that
the fundamental conflict within people
isn't necessarily social versus the
individual.
For Piaget,
the fundamental conflict was between
motivational systems and then between
their expression across time,
within the individual,
and then between their expression across
time,
within the individual in relationship to
all other individuals and to society.
So it was more like a complex problem
that could be solved by a civilized game
than it was a massive force.
That being the Super Ego crushing the
individual into submission.
Now you might say that for neurotic
people,
and neurotic is a strange word,
but we'll say for the sake of,
of,
of argument right now that a neurotic
person who is,
it's suffering sufficiently from the
conditions of their life for
psychological reasons,
that their life is not bearable in its
current form.
They're suffering enough to interfere
with their own movement forward.
Um,
what Freud says about the ego versus the
superego might well be true in the case
of people who aren't well adapted
because they haven't been able to
organize their own motivational drives
in a stable manner within themselves and
then they haven't been socialized
effectively so that they can fit into
the broader community like,
like a dancer might in a complex dance,
then they're much more likely to
experience the social world versus them,
especially if they're rejected.
And,
and,
and they can't gratify any of their
fundamental needs because they're,
because of their inability or their
awkwardness.
So I would say to the degree that you're
suffering from,
from failure,
so to speak,
for one reason or another,
you're much more likely to see s the
social rules as a harsh and repressive
superego.
Obviously they're not doing you any
good.
I would say that's probably more likely
to happen if you're somewhat near the
bottom of a given dominance hierarchy.
And that also means if you're at the
bottom of a given dominance hierarchy,
that you're more much more likely to
consider the spirit of the structure as
an authoritarian spirit and a repressive
spirit because obviously it isn't making
room for you.
And sometimes of course that's the case.
You know what I mean?
There's lots of societies where everyone
at the bottom has nothing and only the
people at the top have something you and
it's,
it's hard to see how you could not view
the culture slash superego as something
that was harsh and repressive and an
authoritarian and crushing under those
circumstances.
So
I also think that it was probably an
idea that was more relevant during the
initial,
during the,
the mid to late stage,
just say of the development of the
industrial revolution.
Because
to work in a factory meant something
very different than to work as a
peasant.
First of all,
if you were working in a factory where
you,
you became bound by time in a way that
human beings had never been bound by
time.
You know,
we,
we time everything seconds means
something to modern people,
you know.
But it took her a long time for the idea
that,
that the time was of the essence for the
organizing,
organizing of human life.
And a lot of that occurred as people
moved into the factories.
And so you can see for example,
the the legacy of that in,
in the modern elementary,
in the modern pre university school
systems because that school systems that
most of you attended with their rows of
desks and their buzzers and their bells
and their recesses are basically factory
structures that emerged from the
industrial revolution that were
characteristic of the way that working
people who worked in factories organize
their lives.
So the bells that go off between periods
and to announce that it's noon and to
tell you that school's out,
those are factory bells.
And so you can see,
you can see echoes of Freud's idea that
the super ego and the ego and the ID or
in conflict by imagining,
for example,
how difficult it is for a very active
six year old,
especially if they're male,
to sit quietly and regulate themselves
by the bell for six or seven hours.
You know,
when they first go to grade one.
And the fact that,
you know,
Freud would say if he was alive,
that the reason that so many people have
attention deficit disorder is because
the demands of the Superego,
so to speak,
in the school system are so excessive
that there's the clash produces
pathology.
Now the pathology is obviously defined
by the situation.
If you define pathology as being unable
to sit down and pay attention to things
that are deadly boring,
well you should be running around
playing and having fun and wearing
yourself to a frazzle,
then that's pathology.
That's attention deficit disorder and
you can treat it with Ritalin.
But that's only because you can treat
anybody with Ritalin.
You know,
as I'm sure many of you know,
so you know,
red is an amphetamine and it makes you
focus more on whatever you happen to be
focused on.
Though there's no real evidence that it
provides any boost in academic
achievement over any reasonable amount
of time.
But if you think about it that way,
you see,
you can understand what Freud meant by
this super ego versus ego conflict or
the Super Ego ego in conflict.
Attention deficit disorder is a perfect
example of that.
And then the pathology is defined by the
circumstance.
If we didn't have schools that are like
the schools we have,
we wouldn't have attention deficit
disorder as a,
as a,
as a pathology now.
And people like to think about it as a
scientific category,
you know,
it's a disease and it's,
it's uh,
diseases like an objective entity.
It's like,
well,
no,
it's not a disease and it's not an
objective entity.
It's a socio cultural construction.
However,
there are certain people who are going
to be more prone to be diagnosed with it
than others.
And that would mostly be,
um,
extroverted,
open extroverted kids because they're
not going to sit down and shut up
because they can't.
They're extremely curious.
And mostly what they want to do is talk
to everyone in play.
Now.
Panksepp Jaak Panksepp Jaak Panksepp
actually has done really interesting
experiments with male rats and he showed
that if you deprive male juvenile rats
of rough and tumble play there,
um,
their prefrontal cortex doesn't mature,
which is also a real hats off to
piaget's theory of play as critical for
higher levels of development and that
you can,
you can also inhibit their tendency to
play using Ritalin.
So
it's pretty sad.
It's in fact it's appalling really.
So,
and I see people in my clinical practice
fairly frequently who come in and said,
well they were diagnosed with adhd when
they were like four or whatever.
It's like,
great.
You know,
pathetic.
It's pathetic that that happens.
Okay.
So a lot of what Freud did was an
analysis of his own fantasies.
And of course we wouldn't consider that
necessarily inappropriate methodology
from the scientific perspective.
But there's something that you need to
know about the scientific perspective
that people never talk about.
Mostly what you learned about in
psychology when you're being taught
experimental techniques in psychology is
hypothesis testing.
Right?
But no one ever talks to you about
hypothesis generation.
The,
the idea there is that while you have a
hypothesis and then you lay out an
experiment and test it,
it's like,
well yeah,
but coming up with a hypothesis to begin
with is like you just don't find them
lying around on the street.
You know,
you have to think the mop.
And so
the scientific process is hypothesis
generation.
That's the first part.
And then hypothesis testing.
And then the third part of it is,
um,
generalization from the test to the real
world in psychologists never talk about
the first step.
They concentrate obsessively on the
second and they ignore the third almost
completely.
So because we just assumed
generalization from lab to the real
world,
we never actually checked to see if
that's true.
And it's very seldom true because the
real world tends to be a lot more
complex and difficult and ornery and,
and uncooperative than the lab does.
But you don't have to discuss your
hypothesis.
So funny because if you're writing a
scientific paper,
you actually generally falsify your,
you,
you lie about how you came up with your
hypothesis basically because you know
you,
you do a literature review and you show
how your hypothesis is extracted as a
logical conclusion from all of this
reading that you've done in the truth of
the matter is,
is you were sitting with your graduate
students in the bar drinking beer and
someone said something funny and then
maybe you thought of something you could
test.
It's like,
you're not going to write that down in
your intro,
but nobody's quite funny because you see
it's,
it's quite amusing because we really
don't talk about how we generate
hypotheses in our paper.
We act as if it's a consequence of
logical,
of induction or logical deduction.
And it's not,
it's,
it's very seldom that,
I mean,
sometimes you're reading along and you
think,
oh yeah,
that idea and this idea of fit together.
But even then you rarely,
like I've found that often when I have
an idea,
it's what comes from this literature
here.
And then from this literature over here
and trying to actually explain how I got
that idea in an introduction.
It's like you can't,
it's just,
you don't have the space.
And so it's quite funny.
I,
I mean,
I don't think that it's,
I don't really think that it's a lie.
It's a format,
you know what I mean?
It's a,
it's a,
it's a mode of doing things,
but,
but it has nothing to do with hypothesis
generation and Freud,
you know,
Freud used his imagination and he,
and he,
and he used his ability to think.
And so that's both imagined that if
production,
which is basically creativity and then
rationality,
which is logical thinking,
and he generated all sorts of hypotheses
and his task wasn't a lab test.
It was a test in practice.
So his idea was,
well,
I've got this notion,
I'll try laying it out in,
in,
in the therapeutic process.
It'll make observations about how that
plays itself out.
Now,
you know,
you could consider that relatively weak
methodology from a scientific
perspective.
But I got to tell you something about
that too.
So,
you know,
okay,
you may know,
you may not know that there were two
streams of animal experiments,
animal behavioral science in the 20th
century,
then they still exist.
One was behaviorism and other was he
thought energy.
Now there's some pretty famous,
he thought logist um,
Conrad Laurens was neatologist.
Dickless Tinbergen was an anthologist.
Frans de Waal now who studied primates
and mostly primates in the zoo,
mostly chimpanzees,
Jane Goodall.
Those people are only theologists.
And what they do is they go out into the
natural habitat of animals,
the blanchards who study rats and their
natural habitat,
or another example.
Um,
it's philosophy,
I think,
who,
who studied gorillas there,
it seemed to be women all the time who
go out into the wilderness and observed
primates.
You know,
it's quite interesting.
Um,
maybe they're more interested in the
social behavior or something like that,
but it is quite striking.
Anyways,
the thought logist what they do is they
go look at animals behaved in their
natural environment.
And the thing is,
is that you kind of end up with a
narrative description of their behavior.
So it's not as technical as the
observations that you produce if you're
working on lab animals.
Right?
But a lab animal and a normal animal are
not really very similar at all.
So,
so one of the things you probably don't
know is that win,
win,
win.
Skinner was experimenting on rats and
skinner.
He was a smart guy,
man.
We learned a lot from skinner.
He kind of laid the groundwork for the
methods that are used by sophisticated
neuroscientists,
especially those who work with animals.
And they're really the ones who do the
work.
He laid down the groundwork for that
sort of investigation.
So it's not like I don't have any
respect for skinner.
It's like he,
he knew exactly what he was doing.
He started his damn rats down to three
quarters of their normal body weight.
So the Skinnerian rat was first of all,
bitterly lonesome because he lived in a
cage all by himself and that isn't how
rats live.
And then he was like starving to death.
So he would work like mad for food.
And so what,
what skinner did in some sense was take
a complex animal and simplify it,
simplify the hell out of it by making it
isolated and starving.
And then he could observe its behavior
under those conditions.
And you could extract a tremendous
amount of information out about how
animals behave by us by using a
simplified animal.
But you lose a lot too.
So for example,
it's pretty easy to get starved board
lab rats to take cocaine.
They'll do it or so if you give them
free access to cocaine,
man,
they'll just take it all the time.
They,
they won't even eat.
But if you have a raft out there in rat
land,
you know,
so that you give them a social
environment and it's,
it's a setup so that it's like a normal
rat would have the rights aren't that
interested in cocaine.
So you know,
you can see how the context there is a
major determinant of the outcome.
So Freud,
I would think of Freud and all the other
clinicians more as ethan logistics.
Then as behavioral scientists,
you know,
and Frans de Waal for example,
he's a great person to read if you
haven't read anything by friends to
wallets,
and he's,
he's like a piaget Gideon for chimps and
what he's observed over a series of
books,
mostly making observations at the rnm
zoo in the Netherlands,
is the emergence of morality among
chimpanzees as a consequence of their
social interactions.
Now,
it's not that simple because the morale,
the ground for morality emerges as a
consequence of the way the chimps
organize themselves into dominant
structures.
So there's a sociological element,
but,
but by the same token,
the chimps are biologically prepared to
inhabit dominance hierarchies.
So there's a continual interaction
between the social,
the social structuring of the behavioral
patterns in the dominance hierarchy and
the evolutionary success of the chimp.
Because think about it this way,
the higher you are in a dominance
hierarchy,
the more likely it is that you're going
to leave offspring.
Well,
so obviously,
obviously what that means is that the
more prepared you are biologically to
succeed at a dominance hierarchy,
the more likely you are to be
successful.
And in human beings,
it's a major issue,
especially for men,
because if they're not successful in the
male dominance hierarchy,
they do not leave any offspring.
So for example,
that a lot of you won't be able to
believe this,
but if you sit and think about it for a
week,
you'll figure it out.
Because it's true.
You have twice as many female ancestors
as you do mail ancestors.
Now you think,
how can that be possible?
And the answer is the APP,
your average forefather.
If every woman has a child,
but only every second man has a child,
then that's exactly what you end up
with.
Every second man,
man,
in that case would have two children.
Right?
But that could easily happen.
So,
for example,
if,
if you could imagine a situation where
one man made 10,000 women pregnant.
Okay.
And you know,
that's not as much of an impossibility
as he might think.
Then you obviously under conditions like
that you'd have far more female
ancestors,
then you would have male ancestor.
So anyways,
so,
okay,
Freud and young and the other clinicians
are basically ethos adjusts and what
they're doing is studying human beings
in their route,
relatively natural environment and
trying to figure out how they work.
And it isn't obvious to me that
prolonged observation over multiple
years of many people in a clinical
setting where you talk about everything
is a less realistic way of gathering
information,
especially for generating hypotheses.
Then assessing 40 undergraduates for 20
minutes in the lab.
You know,
now I think what you get,
what happens is that you can be more
specific in the lab.
So you can do high resolution work in a
lab,
but you can do low resolution work as a
clinician.
And I do think that it's at the low
resolution levels of theorizing that
most of the hypotheses are generated.
Right?
So these things have to play against one
another and it's,
it's not reasonable to presume that one
mode of evidence gathering is superior
to the other in all situations.
So
this is by Freud's Ernest Jones
who was a great admirer of Freud and who
really established the ground on which
the history of psychoanalysis was going
to be written.
Um,
he's been accused of being too much of
an acolyte and I think there's some
truth in that,
but I guess you pretty behalf to be
pretty interested in someone before
you're going to write their biography so
we shouldn't be too hard on them.
In the summer of 1897,
Freud undertook is most heroic seat a
psychoanalysis of his own unconscious.
It's hard for us nowadays to imagine how
momentous this achievement was.
That difficulty being the fate of most
pioneering exploits you up.
The uniqueness of the feet remains once
done.
It has done forever for no one.
Again,
it can be the first to explore those
steps and the long history of humanity.
The task had often been attempted.
Philosophers and writers from Salon to
Monteen,
from juvenile to Schopenhauer had essay
to follow the advice of the delphic
oracle know thyself,
but it also come to the effort.
Inner resistances had borrowed advance
there had from time to time being
flashes of intuition to point the way,
but they had always flickered out the
realm of the unconscious whose existence
was so often postulated,
remained dark,
and the words of hereclitis still stood.
The soul of man is a far country which
cannot be approached or explored.
Freud had no help,
no one to assist the undertaking in the
slightest degree,
worse than this.
The very thing that drove him onward,
he must've dimly divined could only
result in profoundly affecting his
relations or perhaps even severing them
with the one being to whom he was so
closely bounded who had studied this
mental equilibrium.
It was daring much in risking bunch.
What?
Indomitable courage.
Both intellectual and moral must've been
needed,
but it was forthcoming.
Well,
you know,
yeah.
Really,
I mean,
I wouldn't say that prior to Freud and
chip
Western civilization in particular,
Western philosophical,
the western philosophical tradition,
absolutely overvalued the role that
rationality played in the realm of human
behavior.
You know,
emotions and people still think this
way.
Emotions were often considered the enemy
of reason and motivations.
Also the enemy of reason.
And you can understand that,
right?
Because your,
your observations of a given phenomenon
are going to be biased by the emotions
and the motivations that you bring to
the forefront.
And a lot of what scientists we're
trying to do as they learned how to be
scientists,
where to get the damn emotions and the
motivations out of the way and the
personal biases system by esis and the
demand to,
to elevate your career and to be right
and to beat the other primates and so
forth and so on.
They're trying to clear that out so that
you could,
you could attend clearly to certain
classes of phenomena.
And then of course
it was a post renaissance phenomena to
identify the central being of human
beings with rationality.
And furthermore,
there is also a deeper idea than that,
which,
which we all still fall prey to in many
ways.
And that idea was essentially that human
beings had a soul that was separate from
the body.
And so the central nature of the soul
when it was operating properly was
rational.
Now I can understand why humanities
always had the idea that people have a
soul and that there's a body,
you know,
I mean I think it's an obvious
reflection of the fact that we have an
identifiable consciousness that seems
unique and individual and it's wandering
around in a body,
you know,
and they seem separable in some way.
But it wasn't until Freud that people,
I think,
intellectuals,
people who are serious about
understanding the human psyche had to
really grapple with the fact that we
were embodied.
And that our,
our rationality,
because of the way our rationality
really works is that it doesn't even get
to work until it's pre filtered by
emotions and motivations and the body,
you know.
So you could think about rationality as
the master of the ship,
but,
and,
and perhaps that was the way to think
about it before Freud,
but after Freud,
and this is how we think now,
it's like,
no,
no.
First year a body.
And that screens out most everything
instructors,
what you see.
And then inside that you're a set of
motivations.
You're always motivated one way or
another.
And then inside that you're emotionally
evaluating things before they even reach
your rational consciousness.
And then inside that there's a little
rational guy who's,
you know,
trying to zip around and make
intelligent decisions.
But without all that underpinning,
he wouldn't even be able to operate.
And this is,
this is right.
This is why the farthest that people
have gone in the pursuit of our
artificial intelligence is with embodied
robots,
embodied cognitive agents.
It turns out that you can't have pure
rationality without the body.
And so in Freud is you just can't escape
the fact that Freud was the person who
was beating the drum for that
perspective for,
for 50 years.
And he did it extraordinarily
successfully after Friday.
You could never pretend that you weren't
a sexual being or an aggressive being or
a bias being or an unconscious being or
defended being or repressing being are
allying,
being while you were doing whatever it
was that you were doing.
And those things had to be taken into
account.
And you know,
it,
it wasn't much before Freud that Darwin
came up with his Darwinian hypothesis.
And so,
you know,
it was,
it was exactly at that time that it was
necessary for us to understand our
evolutionary kinship or in some sense
even identity with,
with other creatures ranging from those
that were quite like us to those that
were,
are very much unlike us all the way down
the a genetic chain.
There's tremendously important
interrelationships.
And so Freud's idea fit into Darwin's
idea like mad,
you know,
all of a sudden human beings,
we're animals.
They weren't a divine soul in a body.
Now the divine soul idea,
it has its merits,
but the animal idea has its merits to,
and it was Freud who sort of rub
people's noses in the fact that they
were animals along with Darwin.
And that was part of the reason why he
faced such resistance.
So
Freud was definitely an ally of the
evolution of the,
of the idea of evolutionary biology.
And I also think he was a real precursor
in many ways or perhaps the
groundbreaker for,
for the development of fields like
affect of neuroscience,
which,
which you know,
is a relatively new field until well
until the 1960s in psychology,
you weren't even allowed to think that
people thought wasn't until the
cognitive revolution that psychologists
were willing to think that people
thought and that may be animals dead.
I mean everyone else on the bloody
planet knew that people thought,
but the psychologist were refusing to
admit it.
And that was because they were using
strictly behavioral propositions in
their lab work.
And there were some real utility in
that.
And the cognitive scientists came along
in the early 1960s and said,
well,
hold on a minute.
We're not just stimulus response
machines,
even though there are levels of analysis
at which we are.
And then it wasn't until much later,
40 years later,
really 30 years later,
more a lot.
As a consequence of the influence of
Russian neuropsychologist as it turns
out that it became self evident that,
well,
yeah,
I cock cognition,
but you know,
what about emotion and what about
motivation and you know,
can we actually study those as
biological properties?
And the answer to that turned out to be,
yeah,
we certainly could.
And not only that,
that it's obviously it's obvious that
our higher order cognitive functions are
nested within fundamentally emotional
and motivational systems.
And it's also obvious who's in charge.
And it's not the higher order cognitive
functions unless you're blindly naive.
You know,
if even if you look at the brain from a
neuroanatomical perspective,
the strength of the projections reaching
up from the base of your brain,
from places like the Hypothalamus,
which is the ground of fundamental
motivational systems like aggression and
sexuality,
those are like tree trunks,
the little tendrils coming down from the
top of your brain that the do the
regulation,
you know,
the conscious regulation,
those are like little vines,
you know.
So as long as you're reasonably satiated
and everything's under control,
you can pretend that your rational mind
is running the show.
But when push comes to shove,
it's like,
well,
no,
you know,
and it's also pretty obvious that don't
even really like it when your rational
mind is under control too much because,
and this is again a reflection of the
super ego versus Eagle dichotomies.
You're always running around,
you know,
consuming great amounts of alcohol and
other sorts of,
um,
you know,
consciousness altering substances,
which usually alternate for the worst so
to speak,
so that you can do impulsive and crazy
and idiotic things that are really,
really entertaining and fun.
So we don't want to forget about who's
in charge.
And Freud was and still is a very good
corrective for people who are convinced
that they're rational intellect is the
fundamental element of there being.
Now the,
the,
the creation of illness that,
that Jones talked about and it unreal
version I talked about is a variant of
the initiation process that we've been
describing.
And one of the things that,
um,
people like Annenberg Jay pointed out is
that it's often the case that people who
make great discoveries go through a
protracted period of chaos.
Well,
they're making their discoveries before
they put the discoveries together.
And that happened to Darwin for example.
You know,
because Darwin knew perfectly well,
you know,
he's a pretty straight laced Englishman,
whole Darwin.
He knew perfectly well that he was
lighting a bomb.
It was a big bomb.
I mean,
I think you could safely say that Darwin
was the most revolutionary scientist who
ever lived.
You know,
when I was growing up,
it seemed to be Einstein,
but the old Darwin man,
he's,
he's making a,
he's making his move.
And it's especially the case because
Darwin not only outlined natural
selection,
which,
you know,
kept biologists busy for a whole hundred
years,
but he also outlined sexual selection
and all that.
Biologists ignore that for a hundred
years and they're coming back to it now.
So I was hard on old Darwin because he
knew that
the world was going to go from 8,000
years old and created by God to God only
knows how long and the consequence of
somewhat random biological processes,
I mean that's a major league shift in
the old world view.
And you know,
so to the degree that Darwin,
Darwin,
his personality was structured both
explicitly and implicitly by,
um,
Protestant religious presuppositions,
which it was because in many ways he was
a conventional person.
You know,
he was taking a mighty axe to the basic
trunk of is the,
to the thick trunk of his being.
You know,
when he suffered for that,
he had anxiety disorders and it's no
bloody wonder,
you know,
I mean,
if you were Darwin and you weren't
nervous,
you wouldn't have had any idea what you
were launching on the world.
It was a massive revolution,
you know,
in Freud's notion that we were deeply
embedded in our animal selves.
Also was was the precursor to having
people start to comprehend themselves,
not in terms of,
you know,
the last hundred years of history or the
last 500 years of history or maybe even
the entire five years of recorded
history.
But the 7 million years since we've been
separated from our common ancestor with
chimps and the 60 million years since we
were living in trees and the 220 million
years since there were mammals and the
400 million years when our ancestors
were basically lobsters.
And that's a completely different way of
thinking about the world.
And like it's something that we haven't
digested yet.
And I would say for Freud was in the
forefront of the,
of the revolution that produced that
transformation and thinking it was also
hard on Freud and that's what Jones is
pointing out.
You know,
I mean Freud was definitely an anti
religious destroyer like nature,
you know,
he was another announcer of the death of
God.
Freud's idea about religion was that it
was a defense.
Anxiety against death,
sorry,
a defense mechanism against death,
anxiety.
You know,
and to the degree that you guys are
being taught terror management theory,
for example,
it's like that's Freud,
straight and simple.
I mean,
terror management theory was developed
by Ernest Becker and Ernest Becker was a
psychoanalyst even though he was
associate sociologist and he wrote the
denial of death in an attempt to update
Friday and presuppositions.
So Freud is by no means dead.
And the idea of the associations,
you know,
that people,
people's thinking is associational and
that the associations are actually
linked together by emotional similarity.
It's like,
well,
the implicit attitudes,
all of the implicit attitudes,
research is predicated on that idea.
They don't ever credit freud with it,
but it was Freud's initial discovery,
you know,
he discovered that,
that people's thoughts wondered in a
sense,
you know,
and that you could,
you could see why they wondered if you
paid attention.
You could track the underlying rationale
for the connection between sets of
disparate ideas by paying close
attention and you could interpret them.
And that's really what he did with Free
Association.
And I know I would say that I don't
really think for,
I discovered free association.
I think what he did is observed that
many of his severely damaged clients who
I think would have had some variant of
borderline personality disorder if we
would have seen them today.
If you just let them talk,
they would free associate.
And what that was in some sense it was
the,
it was the consequence of the fact that
their personalities had never really
been organized.
And maybe that's because no one had ever
listened to them,
you know?
So I can tell you as far as I can see
that people organize their personalities
by talking and if you don't have someone
to listen,
it's like,
well,
you've got all these ideas rattling
around in your head that are basically
rooted in emotion and they're not linked
together by any coherent narrative and
they're not pruned.
That's another thing.
You need other people to say,
you know,
that's a really stupid way of looking at
things,
you know,
big.
And if you don't have that,
well then,
especially if you've got a reasonably
creative mind,
you're going to generate a whole massive
counter productive,
you know,
but,
but re but potentially founded ideas
that you just can't call.
So,
and Freud figured that out with this
idea of free association.
So we've let people come into his office
and he wouldn't really look at them.
You just let them lie on the couch and
he'd say,
well,
just say whatever comes to mind.
And they'd go wandering around on some
quasi random path.
And Freud would note the connections
between the things they said and infer
what the underlying structure was.
And what he was doing was this
essentially.
So look,
if let's say you go see a movie and then
your friend says,
well,
what was the movie about?
You don't say,
well the first thing we saw where the
credits and then no,
and then you say to your friend all the
credits and then you described every
single movement that all the characters
make,
including when they blink their eyes and
how they move their arms.
And it's like,
you don't do that.
You do something really weird and
mysterious,
which is you take the movie and you
break it down,
you boil it down to,
it's just whatever that is.
It's like,
well,
here's the important features of the
movie.
And you say that,
say,
here's five minutes summary.
It's like you might ask,
well,
why don't you just listen to the five
minute summary instead of going into the
damn movie.
But the weird thing is is you can do
that.
You know,
and you,
you do it without even thinking about
how insanely complex it is.
Well,
Freud was doing that with his clients.
They'd come in there and like lay out
this massive kind of incoherent verbal
chain and he listened and,
and he'd hint at them perhaps what it
meant and he extract out the gist of the
story.
And then if the,
if the advantage to having your memory
reduced to just is that you can only
only have to remember the important
things,
then all of the things that aren't
important,
you can let go of,
you know,
and you see this happening.
If you,
if you ever have a fight with someone,
especially someone that you love,
you know how it happens all the time is
you'll start fighting about something
that's trivial and then both of you,
we'll figure out what we're really not
fighting about that at all.
And then the question is,
well,
what are you fighting about?
And one answer to that is the person who
was the irritating person who started
the argument provoked it say,
because that happens might not even know
what in the world it is that they're
irritated about.
You have to kind of torture them to
death for an hour before they can figure
out what it was that drove the
irritation and manifest it in some
articulated form.
So
in a sense that's bringing things up
from the depths of the unconscious,
you know,
now Freud would have thought of those
things as repressed.
You know,
I don't want to talk about that with you
because I repressed it.
I don't really think that's right.
Often.
I think what happens is that irritation
manifests itself in vague moods and you
have to investigate the mood and the
emotion using different articulated
frameworks,
which is kind of what an argument is
about until you stumble across the
actual articulation,
you know,
and so you're being tortured by your
partner for one reason or another.
Maybe it's because for the 50th time you
left the dish rag on the counter or
something and after fighting with them
for an hour,
you figure out that they had a really
bad day at work for reasons that they
didn't really notice and don't want to
talk about.
So that's Friday and psychoanalysis.
I mean you guys are,
to the degree that you're sophisticated
communicators,
you're going to be doing that all the
time.
I mean,
how many of you actually believe that
everything a person says is what they
mean or that they have perfectly
transparent self knowledge?
I think no one believes that anymore.
Or you know,
if you do believe that well yet hadn't
been paying attention.
I would say that's really the,
the bottom line.
So these creative illnesses are a
consequence of this descent.
And rebirth process that we talked about
before,
and that's much more likely to happen.
You see,
I marked revolutionary at the top.
You know,
when you,
when you're a genius,
you blow apart the basic presuppositions
of an entire culture.
And to the degree that your personality
is predicated on those assumptions and
maybe even your place in the world,
when you chop that over,
it's like you fall too.
You know,
and the whole idea that Darwin had that,
that the environment itself could modify
biological forms through selection.
God,
it's such a brilliant idea because,
well,
because it precisely because it accounts
for why complex forms can emerge in the
absence of an intelligent designer.
Now,
you know,
no doubt there are holes in Darwinian
theory.
You know,
I don't know how many of you know this,
but there's a whole new field of science
that's popped up really in the 21st
century called epogen epigenetics.
It turns out that you can lamarck who
was really the prime,
um,
uh,
what adversary in some sense of Darwin,
dark lamarck believed you could inherit
an acquired characteristics,
right?
For a straight Darwinians like no,
that doesn't happen.
There's lots of evidence now that you
can acquire in here that you can inherit
an acquired characteristic.
So they've showed,
for example with rats that if you
produce a certain amount of terror laden
phobia in a rat,
the rat pups three generations down are
still predisposed in that manner.
And you know,
we just scratched the surface of Epi
genetics.
It turns out that your experience can
alter the structure of your DNA.
It does that by a process,
which I don't understand called
methylation.
And methylation apparently is the
modification of the DNA structure by
additions of little clumps of,
you know,
little chemical units,
little molecules to some in some way we
don't get that encodes actual
environmentally relevant information.
So you know,
that's pretty mind boggling.
So the,
my point is the final word on how we
evolve.
There's not yet,
but Darwin popped up this idea that
while you didn't need an intelligent
designer,
it's like,
oh,
ah,
it's a big problem for,
for a world whose primary notion before
then was that everything was the
creation of something that was not only
intelligent but benevolent.
So I was a little hard on people to come
up with those ideas.
And there's no reason at all for them
not to think that they're completely
insane when it first happens because
they think something that's really deep
and revolutionary that no one else
thinks or has thought up.
And so the probability that you've done
that instead of just going stark raving
mad,
it's like zero.
Right?
So for every actual genius,
there must be 10,000 people who are
convinced in some bizarre,
manic,
paranoid manner that they are genius and
they're not.
So it's rough.
Freud was also
one of the first people to really go
after the idea that we could represent
ideas in symbolic form,
in a manner that was in fact
representational,
but that we ourselves didn't understand.
And I mean,
that's,
um,
that's another revolutionary idea,
right?
Is that we could express that it was
possible to express concepts,
especially those that were associated
with emotion and motivation using non
linguistic representations that needed
to be deciphered.
Now,
Freud's initial theory about that was
that the reason that happened was
because,
and this is where I think he got
something seriously wrong,
but whatever,
like you know,
yeah,
you have to say that with respect.
Freud appeared to think of memory in a
way that we wouldn't think of memory
anymore.
Like he,
he seemed to think something like
when you made,
when you experienced an event,
the event was as the,
a few experienced it,
that that was the event.
So what you experienced was the reality
of the event.
And then sometimes you didn't like the
implication of that event or perhaps you
couldn't understand it,
but you could understand it enough to
know that it was horrible.
It's,
that'd be a traumatic event.
And then just shove that sucker down
into the depths of your being where,
where,
where he didn't have to think about it
anymore and then it would poke itself up
into the nether regions of your
consciousness.
Partly in dreams,
partly and interestingly enough in slips
of the tongue,
you know,
we still call those Friday and slips and
I'll tell you one of the things that's
really cool about doing dream analysis
and psychotherapy is that people make
slips of the tongue tongue all the time.
Tom May slips of the tongue.
Yeah,
well I won't interpret that for now.
But if you listen to people make Friday
and slips while they're talking to you
about their dreams,
they're often telling you exactly what
the dream means.
And it's so cool.
I've seen people,
you know how words can have two
meanings,
right?
Or sometimes three meetings.
Sometimes someone is telling you about
their dream,
they'll use a sentence to describe part
of the dream that similar caneously
accounts for the other part of the dream
without them even know.
Notice it.
And then all I'll do,
cause we're trying to puzzle out the
dream is all tell them back what they
just said.
And they'll go,
you know,
they'll have a little startle.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
that's obviously what that means.
And how in the world people are smart
enough to do that.
On the fly is beyond me.
You know,
it's like,
it's hard enough to talk about one thing
at a time.
But to manage to talk about two things
with the same sentence in a coherent
way.
It's like wait to go brain.
And I think what's happening is we kind
of know that,
you know,
the left hemisphere,
roughly speaking is a linguistic
hemisphere,
right?
But there's a corresponding area in the
right hemisphere that's more or less in
the same physiological location that
this part inhibits tonically.
It's,
it inhibits it all the time.
And it kind of seems that what happens
is now and then that other part of the
brain can get access to speech.
Now it's not very linguistic.
So it sort of stumbles around and maybe
it does it in more symbolic terms cause
it thinks it logistically but now and
then it's got something to say and then
Poof,
both of them are talking at the same
time.
And that is the coolest thing.
Like the problem is,
it's very,
I can't tell you about it,
you know,
because,
and this is one of the problems with
psychoanalytic phenomena is that you
can't really understand them in the
absence of the context that a lengthy
therapeutic interaction provides.
You know,
it's like,
you know how if it is,
if you have an old friend,
he's like you,
you can just say the number of a joke.
You know,
it's like that's joke 42 and they'll
laugh because they know the joke.
You know,
you have this shared history that
enables you to make reference to things
just using fragments and you can't
explain how you do that to someone else
while at the same thing happens in
therapy.
It's like you've talked to this person
for endless hours about the most
important things that are going on in
their life.
And then there'll be communication,
communicated phenomena that emerge
within that context.
And they're,
you know,
they strike you with the force of
revelation,
but you can't communicate them to anyone
else cause you can't conjure up the
entire context,
which is partly why I want to show you
this movie on Tuesday because it's the
only thing I've ever seen that actually
manages to do this.
It's,
it shows Freudian psychopathology
because it gives you enough contextual
information to actually infer it.
So,
so that's really smart.
All that whole free association thing,
man,
that's his idea that it was emotional
systems repressed or not part of the Ed.
You're not.
Because his idea of the unconscious was
somewhat,
it was somewhat confused in a sense.
It depended on when he was thinking
about it.
I mean,
first of all,
the unconscious was a place to put
things you didn't want to pay any
attention to.
But then later it sort of became the Ed
and the Ed was the place of these
primordial drives and emotions.
And so it's not a bad model of the
unconscious,
you know,
especially if you think about it as
something alive and the unconscious is
alive.
It is not a cognitive machine.
And you know,
modern psychologists talk about the
cognitive unconscious.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
There's a cognitive unconscious.
It's like,
well,
what about the rest of them?
You know,
the motivational unconscious and the
emotional unconscious and those things
to the effect of neuroscientists are
onto that anyway.
So it doesn't really matter.
But you know,
Freud got there way early and you know,
he would,
he would note that you see this all the
time,
you're talking to someone,
they're mad at you,
you know,
and you say,
well,
you're mad at me.
And they go,
well,
no,
I'm not.
And you know,
and they face makes it perfectly evident
that they're mad at you.
And so does their tone of voice.
It's like,
okay,
are they lying?
Are they repressing or are they just
more than one thing at the same time?
Well,
you know,
each of those ideas is a perfectly good
idea,
but it's certainly clear that the thing
you're facing is by no means a unified
phenomena.
You say,
well,
you're mad at me.
And they go,
no,
I'm not.
It's like,
sure you're not,
you know,
and if you poke and prod them in,
irritate them and get them to talk
eventually they'll probably figure out
why they're mad because maybe they don't
know or they weren't willing to admit it
to themselves or they hadn't fully
articulated.
And then maybe they'll tell you.
Usually they'll cry first and then
they'll tell you,
well,
that's how it is,
right?
If you watch how these things progress,
it's like it isn't until something
collapses in some sense in the person
that,
and they sort of soften,
I guess they let their persona drop or
something like that until they soften,
they're not going to tell you what's
going on.
So there defendant,
you know,
and that's another freud in idea.
You defend yourself against certain
Sinamatella and certain truths.
It's like,
yeah,
you certainly do that.
And you know,
you do it about,
you pretend that other people are other
than you know them to be.
People do that all the time when they
were in a relationship that they should
have ended like a year ago,
if they had any sense at all.
And they know it.
And it's like,
oh no,
you know this is going to work out.
And they use that stupid voice,
which means that you're only talking
from here.
Right?
Cause they're ignoring the entire rest
of their body and what it's saying,
they know perfectly well.
That's absolute rubbish.
They have no way of explaining to you
why they're doing it.
They don't know themselves.
It's like
Freud,
he knew what he was talking about.
You know?
And if you observe in your own behavior,
your proclivity to do absolutely absurd
and self destructive things at the drop
of a hat and be entirely unable to
control it.
You know,
I mean we talked a little bit about
eating disorders.
It's like there's like 80 or 90 of you
in this room that means at least 30 of
you have an eating disorder.
So you're like having this horrible
battle with your hypothalamus for all
sorts of weird reasons.
And you know,
that's sort of the modern equivalent of
Freud and sexual psychopathology because
you know,
we can sleep around but we don't know
how to eat anymore.
So I don't know if that's much of an
improvement.
So this is Freud.
The mind is a composite of contradictory
drives.
Um,
and Freud actually wasn't,
he wasn't really a drive theorist cause
he was more sophisticated than that,
you know,
because really when he talks about
drives in the broader context of his
writing,
it's clear that he's talking more about
subpersonalities because these drives
manifest themselves as living entities
with their own emotional systems,
their own thoughts,
their own impulses,
even their own ability to speak.
And you know that's true because now and
then you say something when you're
angry,
you think,
well I wish I wouldn't have said that.
It's like who's doing the wishing there?
Exactly.
You know,
it's like it wasn't you that said it
while he said it was because I was
angry.
Well that means you're not your anger.
Well that's Freud's point.
Ego Id ID is anger.
It is the thing that bubbles up all
these impulsive actions and statements
and you're going to detach yourself from
that sucker as soon as you can and
you're going to expect people to forgive
you for it.
Like I wouldn't have said that if he
wouldn't have made me so angry.
It's like,
which is like the worst kind of apology,
right?
It's like,
ah,
I did something rude to you because
you're a horrible and I'm your victim.
It's like that's a great apology.
So
frightened was also pretty damn
sophisticated in his approach to the
unconscious.
So here's some,
here's some functions that he had
identified as early as the 19 hundreds
so he said the unconscious has a
conservative faculty.
It stores memories often unaccessible to
voluntary recall.
It's like,
it's an interesting idea,
right?
So where are those things that you
remember that you could remember but
that you aren't?
Well,
that's a hard one,
right?
It's like,
well,
I don't know where they are,
but they seem to be somewhere when I
want to recall them.
And Freud would say,
well,
they're in the unconscious now.
It's obviously a black box hypothesis,
right?
You know,
because it's not very explanatory.
But at least he had the sense that it
was reasonable to think of them as
somewhere dissolute IV.
The unconscious contains habits once
voluntary,
now automatized and dissociated elements
of the personality,
which may lead a parasitic existence.
Man,
that's smart.
You know,
the idea that that if you did something
habitually that that would produce an,
an automatized system.
You know,
we didn't get there with,
with uh,
with neuroscience until maybe the last
20 years when we actually figured out
that is what happens.
You know,
when you first start doing something,
if it's complicated,
your whole brain is involved in that.
That's why it's so exhausting because
you're really not good at it,
right?
So you're stumbling around like you're
trying to learn a piano piece for
example,
you know,
you make mistakes and you're just a
Klutz at it and then you practice and
practice and practice.
And as you're doing that,
less and less of your brain is involved,
interestingly enough.
And the parts that are active move from
the right to the left and then they move
back and as they move back,
they get smaller and smaller and smaller
until you have a little habit machine
that enables,
you say to play that piece of piano
music or that is really good at biking
cocaine,
depending on what you've been
practicing,
you know,
and then that's a little monster in your
head.
Especially if it's associated with
something like cocaine and good luck
getting rid of that because if you've
taught,
you've automated it and built it into
your biology and Freud would say,
well then the thing just runs as an
autonomous unit.
It's like,
yeah,
that's right.
The nailed.
That's exactly right.
Creative.
The unconscious serves as the Matrix of
new ideas.
That's smart.
Often when you're coming up with new
ideas,
you actually free associate as well.
People call that brainstorming.
So good work.
Freud,
that was real smart.
Mytho poetic.
The unconscious constructs,
narratives and fantasies that appeared
mythic are religious in nature.
It's like,
well,
young took that and just ran with it.
Right,
but Freud never quite made the
connection there,
unfortunately,
because he was so interested in
hammering home the point that human
beings were biological creatures.
He never really was able to grapple with
the idea that,
well,
yeah,
we're biological creatures,
but the mythic poetic function is a
biological function,
and so to say that religion is only a
death,
a defense against death,
anxiety is actually,
it actually contradicts his own theory.
Now,
young pointed that out to Freud.
He said,
well,
you know,
there's a bit of a logical problem here.
And Freud said to him,
and this is what caused their break.
It doesn't matter if we don't go down
the biological determinist route,
so to speak,
then we'll be overwhelmed by a tide of
oak nonsense.
And of course,
well,
the act happened there was the Nazis
first.
They are pretty good at a colt nonsense.
And then there's the whole new age
movement.
So,
and you know,
youngest young is tangled up in that,
even though I don't think he's
responsible for it.
So Freud wasn't going to go there and he
had his reasons,
you know,
but young thought,
well that's just not,
I'm going there.
And that's because young had a mythical
poetic imagination of incalculable
complexity.
And that was just where he was headed.
But,
but Freud figured that out.
It's very,
very smart.
And you know,
a lot of modern neuroscientists and,
and modern psychologists haven't even,
haven't got anywhere near this yet.
You know,
the idea that the unconscious
unconscious has a Mytho poetic function.
It's like,
I don't think you've learned that in any
of your neuroscience courses yet,
but it's coming,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's the case obviously,
since we have mytho poetic structures
that came from somewhere and they're not
just stories,
you know,
that's,
that's a,
that's car.
That's just not a sophisticated way to
think.
So,
okay.
What time is it?
It must be getting close cause you're
all getting rustling.
Two minutes.
Okay.
Well that's good then.
So what we'll do with the next class is
we'll go a little farther with Freud and
then I'm going to show you some,
I think they're shocking.
Be prepared that when I'm going to show
you is a shocking movie and it,
and if it doesn't make you uncomfortable
in many ways and squirm around,
then you're just not paying attention.
So be,
be warned.
Okay.
Friday and psychopathology is not
pretty.
So,
and it's another reason why people don't
like to admit that it exists.
See a suit.
Okay.